If you don't have the charisma
or the talent to be a communicator,
then make sure
that you surround yourself
through your team
or through your partners
and suppliers and advertising
and marketing and PR agencies
with people who understand communication
and they know
how to deliver this communication
on your behalf.
George Kotsolios, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute leaders.
Welcome.
Thank you very much, Michael.
It's a pleasure to meet you
and pleasure to be here.
It's a very, very big pleasure of mine.
There is going to be
some interesting lessons
that we're going to learn today together.
So, we have to get started
because we only have 20 minutes.
George, tell me
a little bit about yourself.
You're a lot into communications,
public relations
in the international spectrum.
Your business is primarily in Dubai,
which I'm very excited
to be visiting in just a few hours.
So, I am extremely excited
to talk to you here before that.
George, who are you?
Okay.
Well, I've been in PR communications
for the last 26, 27 years.
But instead of me starting off
from the beginning,
I'd rather start from the end
because that's I think
where the interest
for you and the audience
who will hopefully be spending
20 minutes of their life
to watch you and me having a chat,
would be more interesting.
And that's because three years ago,
I had just turned 50,
when I actually launched
my own company, in effect,
I became an entrepreneur
at the age of 50.
Not very common.
Yes.
26, 27 years of career
and all of a sudden
I opened my own company.
But the reason that I did
that were purely existential.
Because, you know,
I had just been made redundant
and I needed income
to continue supporting
for myself and my family.
So, this is when I decided that,
okay, it may be time
to try something of my own,
effectively become my own boss.
And there you have it.
And I guess lesson number one,
is it's never too late.
You know, it's you know,
you don't really need
to get your master's degree
or PhD from Stanford University
and jump on the bandwagon
for entrepreneurship all at once.
You know, try and pace yourself.
Go out, experience life,
get a real job, you know, learn.
And the time will come when
you are going to feel ready.
The circumstances are going to be ready.
And the timing is going to be
the right one for you to go
and reach out for your dreams.
Yes? Sorry, you're going to
ask something, Michael?
I have to get into the mindset
of 50 years old existential thread.
You know, you need to bring income
for yourself and your family.
And you're saying, you know,
why don't I start a business,
why don't I become an entrepreneur.
This is something that
a lot of 21, 22 year-olds to say.
Not so many 50 year-olds.
I think that's pretty inspiring.
So, I'd love to just understand
a little bit better
your thought process
as you're making that big decision,
that big leap.
Yeah. Well, I mean,
the number one thing that I believe
any entrepreneur must have
no matter what age he or she is
or how old they are and feel,
is passion and experience
and deep understanding
and knowledge of the area
or the sector that they
are about to embark on.
So, in my case,
as you introduced me earlier,
I have a long experience
in PR, communications journalism.
That's what I was trained to do.
And that's what I've been doing
for a quarter of a century
or more during my career.
And I took that passion
and I turn it into my own startup.
Now, the good thing was
that not only did I continue do
what I knew very well doing
for such a long time,
but in a way I rediscovered my mojo
for lack of a better experience.
Wow.
And that happened because
my first clients,
when I opened my company,
happened to be a young
aspiring tech startup entrepreneur
back in Dubai, where I am still am.
This guy had a long experience working
for other startups until
he took a decision one day to open
his own health tech startup company.
He had the knowledge, the experience
and the passion which he conveyed to me.
You know, there were days
that we will have a long argument
about petty things.
But that helped me understand and realize
how passionate he was feeling
about his own company.
And I guess that is a second lesson,
Michael, for all of you today.
It's without the passion
and without the experience
having done the journey before,
not necessarily as an entrepreneur,
but working for others
is going to be a difficult thing.
It's going to be dangerous,
is not going to be as fluent
as we will feel once you have
this passion inherently inside you.
Right.
So, your time
that experience was pivotal
in your ability to streamline your work,
to know what you're doing,
to be fluent with your business
and to actually be successful at it
because you're actually providing value.
So, what is the business
that you started as an entrepreneur
at 50 years old?
And what skills did you bring with you
from your previous work life?
So, what I do is basically
developing content,
developing messaging,
developing positioning,
developing campaigns,
public relations campaigns that generate
what we call in my language,
in my industry, earned publicity.
So, it's not like advertising
where you go and pay Time magazine
or New York Times
or Gulf news, it was closer
to where I live,
in order to place an advert
in the pages.
This is publicity that you earn
through public relations tactics.
And that is what I do.
And public relations
is very, very important.
In fact, your question brings me
to the third lesson
I want to sort of share
with our audience today.
So, having the timing right for you
to open, it is number one.
Then, having the experience
and the passion to do it
is number two.
But then, being able
to communicate your passion
and communicate this vision
of yours effectively across
your stakeholder universe,
which once you launch a company,
is going to be comprising
of a very diverse group of people
including your employees,
including your B2B partners,
including your B2C consumers
where you want them
to download your app,
including your regulators stakeholders,
government stakeholders,
all the way to investors.
You need to be able to communicate
these to the different audiences.
And basically
that is the third lesson.
If you don't have the charisma
or the talent to be a communicator,
then make sure
that you surround yourself
through your team
or through your partners
and suppliers and advertising
and marketing and PR agencies
with people who understand communication
and they know
how to deliver this communication
on your behalf.
So, you know, I'm surrounded
by a lot of young entrepreneurs.
Communication is not,
I wouldn't say that it's our forte.
I think that coming from more
of an engineering background
and being excited about the product
and technology is one thing,
but like you're mentioning,
our success it often depends
on our ability to communicate.
And it doesn't really matter
how good our product is,
if we're not able to communicate that
it's meaningless.
It's what makes, differentiate
a successful startup from a failure.
I mean,
there's plenty of studies out there,
but one that has really stuck
with my mind is that, out of the hundreds
of startup companies that
they are launched globally, 97 will fail.
Just three of them will make it
a successful exit
or a successful acquisition
or maybe go to have an IPO.
Just 3%.
And I believe firmly
that the key quality,
the differentiating factor between
those who make it
and those don't is the ability
to successfully communicate
the vision, the passion,
the solution and the technology.
Because technology
is pretty much the same.
Solutions are pretty much
the same, because
we've got similar problems, right?
It's how you communicate your solution
to the various stakeholders
you want to engage with
that differentiates you from the crowd.
Michael, you just mentioned
you work for a VC.
I've got a VC clients,
which is actually based out of Greece.
They deal with a lot of European
as well as Dubai and UAE based startups.
And the single thing he keeps telling me
that he and his team are looking into
a young tech startup entrepreneur
who sends them their decks for evaluation,
in order for the fund to invest in them,
is to be able to communicate effectively.
That is the number one.
Because the solution is here today
in one shape and form.
Trust me,
a year or two down the line,
the package is going to look differently.
100%.
So, George, give me a little bit
of insight of what it means
to communicate effectively.
Because obviously
it's a lifelong skill
that takes a lot of expertise
and a lot of experience.
But there must be some things
that we as young entrepreneurs
can embrace to be more cognizant of it
and to really make sure
that the other side
is understanding the value
that we're trying to provide.
So, what are some ways
that we as young entrepreneurs,
can better communicate effectively?
Absolutely.
This is a process, Michael.
It doesn't happen overnight.
You need to have in place resources,
budgets and a robust plan
that eventually is going
to take you there,
eventually going to help you
communicate better.
Let me start
with the three basic steps
of the process.
The first basic step is to be able to
let's say, set your through north.
Okay?
What do I mean by that?
You need to be able
to develop a positioning
for your tech startup.
An overarching positioning
that resonates simultaneously
with every single different target group
you are trying to engage with.
And once you have
these solid in your mind,
then what you need to do
is to develop what we call
in our business,
a key messaging platform.
Which is, imagine like a house,
I'll try to make it a picture for you.
Please.
Imagine you've got a house.
There is a roof on top of the house.
Inside this roof, this is where your
overarching positioning statement
about your humble tech startup is.
Okay?
Which actually tells
where you want to go.
What is the solution
that you are developing,
why you are the best person
and your best company
to bring it to market.
Right.
Under this, let's say roof,
you've got windows, okay?
Now, depending on the complexity
of your tech startup,
you are going, and the number
of stakeholder audiences
that you want to impart,
you will have
an equivalent number of windows.
Right?
Right.
The cases that I have dealt with
and I have dealt with startups
in the health tech industry
from the last mile delivery industry,
from the fintech industry,
the food industry, e-commerce,
you name it, I've done it all.
The number of target audiences
varies between three and five
depending on the complexity.
The three key audiences are usually B2B,
which means these are the partners
that you want to influence
to bring over.
Number two is the consumer.
You know, the people that
they are going to be making use
of your application,
whether you are health tech
or a food delivery app.
And the third is the investors.
Because startups, you know,
they need to encourage investment
from VCs, for private equity firms
and individual investors
and so on and so forth.
So, for each of these three,
let's say, key target audiences,
then you need to have
another opening statement
that resonates uniquely to them.
Okay?
And once you communicate
uniquely to them,
then you need to have
what we call a series
of three normal key messages
that bring that sub opening to life.
It sounds a little bit complicated.
If it's not very clear,
please ask me to explain it again.
No, no, no. It's perfectly clear.
And the thing that makes
most sense is this
is the fact that you need
to make it unique to the person
that you're talking to.
I think I'm assuming that one
of the biggest pitfalls of entrepreneurs,
especially young entrepreneurs,
is that you're using the same messaging,
the same deck,
the same PR released
to the every single person.
But that's not necessarily
the message that they want to hear.
And you have to stand out
from the crowd.
You got it exactly right.
You know, the message
that the investor wants to hear
is completely different
to the one that the consumer
wants to hear.
And definitely not similar to the one
of the B2B audience wants to hear.
Right?
So, that is a philosophy
that I have brought
and I have developed
to communicate, to develop rather,
the messaging for my tech startup plans.
So, that is the first step
of the process.
Once you've got these all done
and dusted and signed off by the client,
then the next step is what we call
media training and message delivery.
Then we sit
with the tech startup founder
and co-founders and owners
and we take them through
a rigorous four hour session.
The last few months
we'd been doing it over Zoom.
But previously, of course
it was physical meetings
where we have on the back
your drop, you know, the deck
that we have developed
for the messaging.
And then we take them through
a process which includes
a number of a real life
case studies explaining to them
the difference between
a good interview and a bad interview.
Then will take them
through practical sort of workshops
where we try them, you know,
how they answer a question
before they go through the trade
and how they answer that at the end.
So because, you know,
as we said earlier,
communication is key, you know.
It's great to have the positioning right,
the messaging right.
But if you don't have it naturally,
if you're not a natural communicator,
then this media training helps people,
help them to organize their thoughts
and help them to sort of
know what to say, when to say it
and what not to say,
which also also very, very important
That sounds very important.
And the third step is engagement.
Right?
So, once we've got the messaging right,
once we've got the training all sorted,
then it's time to engage
with our universe, stakeholder universe.
And that includes
a number of stakeholders.
It could be for instance,
a panel discussion over Zoom
where the startup entrepreneur
will go and be part of the panel.
So, he needs to have his messaging
there available in his mind
and be able to deliver that message.
It could be a TEDx speech.
You know, being there 10, 15 minutes,
talking about the solution, the problem,
but also making it relevant
to his company.
Right.
Or it could be a media interview,
live TV or live radio,
which is very, very unforgiving,
by the way.
Because if you say something live
on telly, on radio and it's wrong,
then you know, khalas,
it's now going to flop, obviously.
But also what we do, as a company,
as a business, is then
we package this information
depending on the occasion
and into what we call,
press releases or feature articles.
And then we take
these written information
and we work with our media contacts
to make sure that we place them
in the magazines, in the newspapers,
in online publications and so on.
And that's how
we start developing the visibility,
the awareness that I am here,
I am the owner of this company.
My company does X, Y and Z.
We are solving this problem.
And that's how eventually,
you are going to get noticed.
Otherwise, it doesn't matter
if you have the best solution,
as long as nobody knows it,
it's not going to be good enough.
I love it.
George, that was inspiring
and fascinating.
Thank you so much for sharing
from your experience.
I think most of all
it's inspiring to see somebody
that is so passionate
about what they do.
In the end, your passion stands out
from every word
that you said here today.
So, thank you very much for that.
I want to thank you for being
so generous with your time.
And before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Oh, ouch.
Okay.
You go with that.
I would say curios is one.
And that comes
from my journalism background.
I started as a journalist.
In journalism,
PR is very, very sort of relevant
in a way, because,
if you know how to write
as a journalist, then you know
how to write about everything.
So, curious is one.
And I would also say inquisitive,
which is pretty much similar
to curiosity.
So, that's two.
You want the third one as well.
Well, the third one,
I think I'm going to grant myself,
which is passionate, because
I've done over 250 of these episodes
and I can see very clearly
the passion that you're bringing
towards this, and it's just remarkable.
So, thank you for that.
Wow. Thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Michael.
Thank you.